that's why I don't agree with it cuz
it's a medically assisted version it's
like there's always an option to off
yourself at any moment like you could
literally just throw yourself off a
bridge like what there's hell so you
just called them
[Music]
a so there's uh something that happened
in Canada that people are sort of
divided on it's kind of like a new thing
that's going to take effect next year
they're going to allow medical assisted
suicide damn w
they already have it for certain things
usually it's when you have like a
physical ailment you're suffering and
there's no cure that's usually when they
do it right but now they're going to let
people who are physically okay but
they're just addicted to drugs W they're
going to let them where Canada Canada
yeah they're going to get they're going
to open up the option of like hey if you
just feel like there's no way out just
kill yourself no what the [__] they are
they are really standing on just the
just kill yourself that's crazy is there
limit like you got to be like 21 I think
you just have to be an adult yeah I
don't know cuz I feel like a drug addict
is probably not in the right state of
mind or they're in the best state of
mind right so they're probably not going
to's like I swear to God I thought this
over man I think I'm going to do
it yeah their decisions aren't probably
coming from a place where they're like
yeah I'm happy with that decision can I
be objectively emotionless let's hear it
I would like to so you're going to be
one of us right now let's go yes um I
think you should do I think because we
have like you from a macro perspective
have an overpopulation problem on this
planet as a human species I'm kind of
like okay I thought they said if they
scattered us like you know we wouldn't
be overpopulated but they're not going
to it's not it's not like everybody some
one new world power is going to pick us
all up and Scatter us have equal
resources we're actually underpopulated
in the Western countries but the overp
populations are like China India on the
planet though you know what I'm saying
just the idea of this Disneyland but
again that's being objectively
emotionless like that's the essence of
humanity though can make their own
decisions is what I'm saying but like
they can get help doing it so it doesn't
have to be like painful or scary in in a
certain way I'm against that is that
considered suicide then because you're
still yeah yeah you're still making the
choice that's what I'm saying like yeah
the way the process works is that let's
say that you're one of these people that
you're you feel like there's no hope for
you you apply for it and you still have
to wait 90 days or something and at the
end of the 90 days if you still want to
do it then give you the shot and you're
just out damn hell there's like a 90day
cooling off period yeah there's like a
90day you sure about this you get cold
feet yeah 90day period to fix your
mental
health pretty much yeah if you guys have
like you know mental illnesses and you
want to you know offer yourself come to
Under the Influence Channel we do Dollar
Store therapy there and you can submit
your questions and we go yeah they'll
probably kill themselves anyways after
that do you have Dollar Store rehab doll
store therapy that's dope yo but now
being being serious though I I uh I OD a
year and a half ago oh wow and I had
spent probably 3 years just so at 17
when I ran away I did there was a full
year where I did Molly and xans just
every day worked past that and then my
drug of choice after that was uh perks
and it was to a point where I literally
I used to say this as a not a joke but
like I used to search out fetty perks
cuz they hit harder than real perks so
that's that's how far gone I was and at
the same time I struggled with my mental
health too like I've always kind of
wanted to kill myself so the the only
thing that really saved me
was my friends huh like I would hang and
and my mom like I would hang on to life
for them but I think if in that current
mind state if I had the choice to be
like assisted suicide I would have taken
it and sitting here today who I am today
like I I no I I would never yeah I would
I would I would like I I think I got
blessed that I'd survived my overdose
and since that day I I haven't touched
one so you think that like them even
making it available to people that are
suffering from just drugs like their
body's fine that kind of almost makes it
harder to get out of it right yeah
exactly like I feel like it's giving
them that that that eject button on life
it's like they're probably going to take
it like you know what I mean like
there's a lot of people that probably
would take it that if they had been able
to persevere through like you you may
have been able to get out of that what
if they what if they didn't have like
friends or a mom though Community but
like I I think that overall like there's
a lot of people that may contemplate
suicide and there's a maybe not a
million but there's definitely multiple
ways out of it like fixing your to I
don't even know how like some people you
know what I mean like some people might
find something may be God it may just be
like yourself you know what I mean but
like it may just be chemical imbalances
that sh time will pass you know like but
uh or just a tickle fight old fashioned
tickle fight exactly man bring some joy
to your life it's interesting cuz
there's a Doctor Who's um he's one of
the doctors that actually does medical
assisted suicides and he said that when
he does deal with people that have
substance abuse that they don't tend to
tell him that they want to kill
themselves they don't they don't tend to
ask for medical assistant but he's
saying that with this he feels that it's
going to be pushing it on them now bro
yes it's like ever thought
about alterate I I promise you when
you're high and like addicted to drugs
the only thing you can think about is
your next fix nobody what is sitting
there being like I want to kill myself
all they're thinking about is where the
[__] can I find my next perk yeah that's
what he's basically saying so he's
saying that like adding that into the
equation is almost like bringing it up
all the time to somebody like hey have
you thought about this have you kind of
you hand out bro shorts bro have you
heard of this option yeah yeah it be
like that it's crazy I I this might
sound kind of grim but like if if
someone does reach that point of of
suicide I
think you have to do it yourself like
that's the most final choice to
everything in life so you have to do
that yourself that is interesting right
it's like why don't they do it
themselves you're putting it on someone
else if you're that passionate about
something but I do get it if let's say
you're old and you're you have you're
you know you're going to die yeah
whatever cuz they do that in what the
Netherlands or whatever where like you
know you're about to go when you're on
your deathbed I think that's different
than when you're like not on your death
bed it's more like a mental health issue
that you have yeah and that's what
they're that's what they're trying to
really uh accentuate here is that these
people don't have physical ailments
whatsoever you could have a perfect body
but your mind is just like dunsky and
they're like oh you're eligible if you
you know well there's two schools of
thought right so there's one like if you
look at the one extreme end it's it's no
this should be illegal everyone just has
to go like when they are going to go and
some people even like try to put them on
life support even though they're about
to like be gone you know and you can't
even do it cuz it's they they see it as
like unethical and illegal then you have
the other side where it's like you
should control your own destiny your
body whatever you want to do if you want
to go you want to go and that should be
your choice and I think most people are
like in the middle right where they're
like if you're living pretty painful
every day you have some like incurable
disease and you're just dealing with
major suffering then maybe yeah or
you're about to go anyway I feel like
most people are like that makes sense
but where people will probably feel bad
is when it's like why when if you just
want to do it one day like and I and I
think it's because you picture your own
life or your family members but at the
same time what are these people living
like I don't know their story I don't
know how if if they have friends if they
have like they might just want to get
the hell out of this world you know and
then who am I to say no you stay here
and work on it you're not going to be
accountable for I'm not helping them
that's true but it makes me feel bad
knowing that they want to go out right
so then I'm trying to prevent them but
I'm not doing anything to help this
person get out of that you're just
saying like don't exactly so I'm making
it illegal because it makes me feel
better but like I don't and I'm telling
them just fight just fight you can you
can do it but I'm like you have no right
to but you're not actually going to tell
them that right what if you do this what
if so I do like they have to do it
themselves so let's say there's if you
really want to do it there's a gun at
the end of the tunnel but the tunnel is
like a bounce
house you have to make your way all the
way through the bounce you're going to
jump and have the the time of your life
and then by the time you get to the end
then you choose damn after all that fun
nah and you get the bounce back point
though because that's exactly what subin
went through we had a buddy that wanted
to kill himself and I didn't know that
he wanted to kill himself I had no idea
and one day he asked me to like uh help
him buy this motorcycle because his plan
was he was going to ride a full speed
and smash into a truck so I helped to
buy this bike thinking he just wanted a
bike and then he got on it and he had so
much fun that he's like I want to
[__] live and do this oh you did you
did him a favor yeah but it could have
been a very much not favor so like that
I did to be
uh subjectively emotional it's like you
approve the program right but it's
duplicitous we learned that today right
where where you have 90 days before they
can approve your application in that 90
days they're giving you all these
[__] hotlines to get off of it and
then if you don't [__] fall into
these hotlines that help save your life
at the end of the 90 days they say oh we
have to reject your application you
didn't qualify bro you know what might
even you know you must go skydiving you
must swim with dolphins must enjoy life
you must go to Hawaii for a couple days
I sentence you to Bali how much more sad
let's say you're so sad you want to kill
yourself then you do this and they
reject your application you feel even
sadder but you got to pull the trigger
yourself though but hey remember like
you're not sad enough yeah that's why I
don't agree with it cuz it's a medically
assisted version it's like there's
always an option to off yourself at any
moment like you could literally just
throw yourself off a bridge like what
there's hell so you just called them a
[__] like what if it's a religious
thing where they they can't do it
themselves cuz they they're like well I
won't go to
heaven still suicide I'm sure in God's
eyes you killed yourself what it's a
placebo pill it's medically assistant
you take this pill you obviously don't
die and they're like you're the only
person who's never die a sign they do
that to everybody what they should do is
give you DMT like like they tell you
that it's they're killing you and they
just pump you with they just give you
some mushrooms yeah and then you just
think you meet God real quick and then
you come back and you're like you know
what I should probably go do something
what they think they're the chosen one
they start acting cocky dude oh [__]
yeah they become the savior of like
everybody that's a good argument cuz
what if we're trying to save someone
who's like the next
Hitler and we're like dude just pursue
your passions and he goes you know what
I don't like them Jewish people you're
right and you're like no no no no no no
he just got rejected from art
school it makes me think of that
statistic where they said like the uh
people who have attempted suicide and
failed the suicide and they ended up
alive they um they recall jumping off
and immediately regretting
it so like it makes you think what if
you did just knock somebody out and then
they it's just a a little like sleeping
thing and they wake up and they're like
oh I'm not dead like damn at my last
moments I really regretted it and that's
what it took to like want to live so let
them die a little bit yeah a little bit
a little bit you know little bit thigh
get close just a taste of death I like
the DMT too cuz that's I heard what what
happens you just see the light and then
pull yourself out cuz sometimes for a
lot of people coming damn close is what
it took yeah it's true very true put a
gun in your mouth and go oh [__] and
then you pull it out like that it's just
rushing I feel like I feel like the gun
in the mouth is is so intense but I've
heard that with people jumping off
things that they survive cuz they hit
water and then they live and then
they're like yeah I'm not doing that
again yeah that was whack yeah life is
better than that some kind of Hardcore
Epiphany like finally unlocks at your
like darkest deepest moment always right
yeah so it's like your back's against
the wall but then it is true if you if
you just like feel like that and you get
this medically assisted suicide it's
almost like you you miss out on that
completely yeah you don't get that
lesson suicide is so hard to do like
like I think that is like that explains
it right killing yourself is a super
scary super hard thing to do so it
really makes and if you go through with
it it really makes you think like
sitting on the edge of that bridge like
is this truly what I want and then
medically assisted makes it so easy and
it takes that that responsibility out of
your hands true so if you do it you're
kind of a puss yeah honestly but like
you're trying to Al four out of life
anyways like you're you're kind of being
a [__] what if like hey this is
medically assisted but it hurts like a
bit like I don't want to do it medically
assisted is like four nurses just stab
you to death do they do they charge for
this yeah what's the fee yeah imagine
who are you billing after that's what
I'm saying like what he's going to
charges credit card and then he doesn't
have to pay the bill after
anyway if it's happening in CA that's
probably tax it's probably people's tax
money yeah hell no that's crazy that I'm
taxpaying to murder people yeah yeah
that's tight wait so this is past
already next year it goes into effect
that so Canada also lets people like
beat seals with clubs too yeah that's
[__] up what I forget why that's a
thing seal clubbing like I I watch cuz
it's like a cultural tradition or
something that shouldn't be a cultural
tradition I watch oh this dude walking
on the ice with a seal limping away from
him and he's just like and it's the
cutest white little like
seals are like Sea Dogs and and I don't
even know I don't know if he's eating it
or if he's like farming these seals I
doubt he's eating it I got to look this
up n bro don't look at that [__] up I
want to see that I'm going do on private
mode hey somebody takes your phone to
look at the search history and it's just
seal clubbing I wish it was just
[Music]
por